saint quentin en yvelines première
communauté d'agglomération à avoir
approuvé son plan local de déplacement
révisé dans ce contexte la semaine
européenne de la mobilité est l occasion
pour l'agglomération d'animer des forums
d'innovation au sein des entreprises du
territoire
tout au long de la semaine l'intérêt de
ce type d'initiative en entreprise et
devenir au contact des usagers salariés
typiquement cette année on a mis en
place un nouveau service le service de
la vélostation à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines élite aisée de
venir présenter le service aux salariés
en leur montrant pour ceux qui viennent
par exemple en train la possibilité de
faire le dernier km en vélo pour airbus
défunte chaîne space dont un des sites
est implantée à elancourt
cette mise en place est née notamment de
la volonté de six entreprises du
territoire de créer un plan de
déplacement inter entreprises
nous cherchons développer les moyens de
transport alternatifs pour deux raisons
la première c'est baisser
le nombre de voitures sur le site la
deuxième c'est toucher une population
que l'on recherche qui sont les
passionnés d'informatique très citadin
qui n'aiment pas la voiture des citadins
qui refusent de plus en plus la voiture
au profit de solutions innovantes de
transport partagé comme le covoiturage
ou le vélo services qui sont autant
d'alternatives à la voiture individuelle
complémentaire des transports publics
en fait pour venir le matin
je dois faire que 25 minutes de bus donc
je me suis dis qu'effectivement une
location de l'eau ça pourrait justement
simplifier les déplacements les nombreux
partenaires de l'événement comme la sncf
hourtoule ou vélostation sont au rendez
vous de ces forums de la mobilité en
entreprise